voilà pour ce film et toutes les
questions évidemment qu'il qu'il pose
quelle place pour les handicapés mentaux
à l'école au travail dans la société
pourquoi encore autant de réticences
comment expliquer que 40 ans après la
loi ce soit toujours si difficile et
puis que faire quand on est parent d'un
enfant handicapé est une question qu'on
a envie de vous poser
évidemment les douars qu elle puisque
vous êtes le réalisateur de ce film est
le père de vincent on en débattra
également avec marie anne montchamp
c'est une secrétaire d'état aux
personnes handicapées qui a porté la loi
de 2005 vous précis dès aujourd'hui
entreprises et handicap avec pierre
lagier de l'union nationale des
associations de parents et amis de
personnes handicapées mentales
votre frère était trisomique 1 je crois
vous présidez l'association chrysalide à
marseille et puis avec l'ancien
éducateur spécialisé julien père fumeaux
auteur notamment de voulez vous de nous
ça c'était en 2006 et de ses surdoué de
la relation et on voit bien vincent en
est un dans le film que vous avez écrit
en 2014
edouard qu elle d'abord il est où
vincent il va bien il travaille il est
au boulot là il est au boulot
normalement ils travaillent le matin
mais
et son ca p nous allons repasser à
l'arrêt et essayer c'est peut-être
l'idée on va essayer en tout cas et ça
s'inscrit dans ce cadre
sa vie personnelle on voit dans le film
qui il a une envie d'autonomie qui va au
delà du travail
c'est vrai ouais c'est vrai que de toute
façon il a voulu faire ce travail-là
passe pour être au contact des gens
parce qu'il avait le possible de faire
l'horticulture et vraiment ce qu'il
cherchait c'était le contact donc oui sa
vie personnelle manduel va à peu près
bien vous dire que aller stable calais
acquise elle est définitive
non mais il a une petite amie amy
peut-être le père est prudent ou est-ce
qu'il est tenu à l'écart est grand il
est prudent d'abord il brûle c'était
difficile vous êtes réalisateur c'était
difficile d'accepter de filmer sa propre
vie son propre fils est d'abord c'était
votre intention de départ de faire ce
film avec votre fille alors j'en avais
déjà fait en fait il ya plusieurs années
dans les années 90 et j'avais justement
préféré ne pas le faire avec mon fils en
disant que c'était trop compliqué et les
choses étant
ce qu'elles sont je me suis dit aussi
qu'il était important que je puisse dire
ce que moi je pense je suis un
documentariste un peu plus réduire et
l'idée de mettre des commentaires dans
les films gêne et donc pour moi dans le
documentaire il ya toujours des trous et
en l'occurence j'avais envie qu'il y en
ait pas trop donc je me suis dit la
façon de résoudre cette question c'est
de ne mettre moi-même dans le
documentaire de telle façon que j'ai
subitement un un droit un droit de
parler c'est que dans un documentaire
normal je ne m'accorde pas donc voilà
c'est un vrai documentaire ça ce petit
nuance près que je suis dedans et que
comme ça ça m'autorise à dire ce que
éventuel danger a dit légal breton et le
co réalisateur de ce documentaire est ce
que sans votre présence constante votre
investissement j'ai envie de dire votre
militantisme parce que d'être quand même
un militant pur et dur là-dessus
vincent aurait pu faire tout ce qu'il
fait aujourd'hui d'être derrière lui
tout le temps pas tout le temps mais il
est vrai que le widzew l'aide
je l'aimais et je pense que ça fait
partie de sa réussite mais je suis pas
seul à l'aider à vous allez aussi sa
mère vous avez aussi toute une série de
gens autour
là on voit moi parce que
parce que c'est le principe du film mais
je suis pas seul sans vous il aurait eu
cette volonté là sans vous tous je sais
pas en tout cas c'est un gosse
volontaire c'est un gosse si vous voulez
jusqu'à ces dix ans il ne tenait pas
debout
il avait la trisomie n'est pas à
strictement parler un handicap mental
c'est un handicap globale qui gêne le
développement d'un certain nombre
d'organes il pas debout hidayat vous on
le voit faire du karaté une voiture
noire d'impressionner parmi les
bizarreries que peut générer la trisomie
en l'occurrence pour lui ça a été les
muscles des cuisses qui n'étaient pas
dans laxe normal et donc il ne tenait
pas les rotules et donc il se casser la
figure je sais pas je ne peux d'un de
mes temps dix quinze fois par jour
pendant des années des années il en
pleurait et on avait espéré avec sa mère
que ça se résolve et finalement non et
il ya passé deux ans à l'hôpital
quatre opérations plus que lourdes on
voit les cicatrices par instants dans le
film
donc c'est un gosse qui a beaucoup de
volonté
comme tous les gosses qu'obama qui ont
souffert qui ont eu des problèmes de
santé
il ya une volonté de faire ce que dit
ses copains du cep d'ailleurs on lui en
veut plus que nous on la fin c'était
quand même longtemps sa réponse un c'est
aussi le premier handicap c'est aussi le
fait que où les mouvements de femmes
diront la même chose on leur demande on
demande en demande toujours plus
incertain et les personnes handicapées
sont obligés d'avoir d'avoir une volonté
et dead
de faire toujours plus que les autres et
la cua choix il peut pas se laisser
porter il est un peu porter c'est à dire
qu'il est aidé mais il peut pas se
laisser porter au sens où si lui n'a pas
la volonté ça marchera pas quelle
énergie tout de même déployé pour
appliquer la loi
parce que c'est la loi c'est ça c'est
votre loi celle de 2005 c'est la loi que
nous avons effectivement fait fait voter
en 2005 qui en fait tout simplement
dispose que la personne doit être dans
la cité et donc faire face au handicap
ça n'est pas simplement interroger la
personne s'est interrogé l'ensemble du
collectif qui autour d'elles permet sa
participation et permet au delà de la
participation sa citoyenneté et en os en
effet seule la personne est fragile mais
sans la personne rien n'est possible
c'est ce que c'est ce dont vous portez
témoignage directement aujourd'hui
devant nous mais aussi dans ceux dans ce
magnifique documentaire évidemment parlé
longuement parce que votre foi n'est pas
seulement un succès pour l'instant
largement pas appliquée on peut le dire
beaucoup de chemin mais bon c'est
évident regardons aussi le wiiware à
moitié plein mais là en effet beaucoup à
dire les choses comme les choses à
moitié il ya un très beau moment dans le
film il ya beaucoup de très beaux
moments dans ce film et y en a 1
particulièrement poignant c'est quand
vincent signe son contrat
il entre dans la vie active il rejoint
l'autre monde
et voilà
tu viens de signer un contrat en poche
le travail et la politique toussaint
nature on dans la société de tous les
hommes à la fois c'est assez important
et
combien ont la chance de vincent combien
de d'adulte handicapé j'ai envie de
préciser d'ailleurs handicapés mentaux
mais on fera le détail tout à l'heure
sont au travail
aujourd'hui on se bat pour le meilleur
du nerf peu qu'est ce que vous entendez
par milieu ordinaire mieux normales avec
les autres
oui l'église une autre à dans un parc
devant des structures spéciales et les
seat et oui un dehors de cette édition
devenus des esat maintenant un
établissement et service d'aidé par le
travail
moi j'ai commencé mon boulot
d'éducateurs dit je sais pas trop
comment enfin mon travail c'était de au
sein d'une équipe diem prod institut
médico-professionnel où étaient
regroupés des jeunes dits handicapés
mentaux c'était justement de faire
sortir autant que faire se peut dans le
milieu ordinaire du travail dans le
milieu normal donc est bon j'ai
travaillé sept ans de 69 et pour les 7
ans qui ont suivi
ali un pro de suresnes dans les
hauts-de-seine à cette époque 80% des
jeunes sortez en milieu ordinaire de
travail jeudi dès jeudi ferrite et
ensuite je suis parti travailler ali un
pro de palaiseau dans l'essonne de 76 et
pour les 15 ans qui ont suivi très
précisément 38 % de jeunes dit
handicapés mentaux parce que j'aime pas
beaucoup ces termes handicapés sont
allés travailler dans un milieu
ordinaire les autres aller vers des esat
ou seat et c'est la loi qu'à voir la loi
oui moi j'ai travaillé donc 30 ans à
plein temps pour intégrer dans le cadre
de l'intégration de jeunes dans le
milieu ordinaire
puis est arrivé l'âge de la retraite
depuis un certain temps j'ai travaillé
jusqu'en juillet dernier d'ailleurs j'ai
travaillé sept ans à mi temps à temps
partiel pardon dans une structure dont
je suis un petit peu membres fondateurs
et mon travail c'était d'intégrer des
gens avec un handicap mental ou
psychique
alors les handicaps physiques et le
handicap le plus difficile à faire
passer dans le monde de l'entreprise ou
ailleurs ça s'est passé terrible année
mais pour les handicapés mentaux ou
psychique nous sommes dans le cadre du
handicap mental je peux vous dire qu'au
plus ce thème pas sur moi c'est facile
de trouver un job pour des personnes qui
ne te donne à redon gens à comprendre
plus on fait de loi écoutez moi c'est
vrai non pardon je comprends mais non
mai 1975 nous fait une première loi vous
me dites y en a - après la première loi
la société a changé ma la mouche on est
d'accord ça et le monde du travail ne
fait pas de cas des le monde d'autres me
fait moins malade aujourd'hui qu'avant
l'exigence est considérable les méthodes
de recrutement les méthodes de
management quoi qu'on en dise quoi qu'on
en rencontre parce que il arrive qu'on
ce qu'on se pare de belles couleurs pour
faire illusion mais quand on parle de la
responsabilité sociale des firmes force
quand même est de constater que les
barrières à l'entrée sont terribles et
que le monde du travail lui même créé
des handicaps considérable qui veut dire
que nos compatriotes avec des
déficiences intellectuelles comme ce
peut être le cas de ceux qui sont
porteurs d'une trisomie 21 est bien
peuvent vivre cette confrontation de
manière très brutale c'est vrai à
l'école c'est vrai dans la formation
professionnelle et et c'est vrai dans le
monde du travail s'il n'est pas attentif
plus dur avec la crise qu'avant la crise
vous savez pas de lien bah je dirais
qu'avec la crise vous avez bien toujours
quelques phrases de gens qui vous disent
on a déjà assez à s'occuper avec le
chômage on verra pour la personne
handicapée après enfin ça devient quand
même un discours difficile à tenir
politiquement c'est quand même un peu un
peu difficile de le dire frontalement ça
se pense mais ça ne se dit pas en
revanche le monde du travail et est
difficile oui allez-y le monde du
travail est le travail lui-même a changé
les les activités des métiers sont plus
les mêmes et les
les métiers que peuvent faire une
personne qui présente un handicap mental
sont moins importants que ce qu'ils
étaient il ya vingt ans et a trop de
temps donc quand on dit qu'il y avait qu
à vous avez dit 80% je crois de
personnes qui allaient dans le monde du
travail
69 76 voix je crois que sérieuse ça
représente quand même pas à mon sens la
situation telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui deux mois je t'aime en
association en a 700 places de 700
personnes accueillies en esat avec une
structure qui existe ainsi atteint pour
ceux qui les assiettes et ceux qui
connaissent les calices d'être par le
travail donc 700 en 700 personnes
accueillies 700 travailleurs est une
structure qui s'appelle les atours les
murs qui a pour objectif de faire entrer
ces personnes dans un monde ordinaire
avec un s'est dit pas par le stage ou a
fait avancer dit et donc c'est que donc
on a la volonté de cette inclusion dans
le monde du travail est alors je donne
un chiffre qui n'a rien à voir que 60% à
80%
c'est 4 entre cinq et dix personnes
disons pour être optimiste année qui
rendait sur 700 - donc c'est moins de 1%
et mais alors appris à mon sens c'est
lié aussi quand même à la société
elle-même et au regard que porte la
société sur le handicap le
la société en général n'est pas prête du
tout accueillir les personnes
handicapées et on voit bien en termes de
d'accessibilité en termes d'accès aux
soins en termes de d'école il ya des
progrès et la loi est la loi de 2005 est
une bonne loi si elles étaient
appliquées complètement ce serait même
la loi qui dit edouard qu elle pendant
tout le pendant tout le film
et puis c'est pas tout dire on voit bien
je prends un exemple dans le film moi
qui me parlait de ce film m'a beaucoup
plu parce que alors ils montent
effectivement un cas qui est un peu
exceptionnel quand même malgré tout mais
qui manque quand même les difficultés
les réactions de tous ces longs mois il
ya quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup frappé
c'est le pari sme entre le professeur de
karaté et le professeur de lycée alors
je suis pas bien qui parle et c'est le
jeune du centre de formation des
apprentis oui voilà le patron le
responsable qui parlait qui dit on ne
peut pas attendre vincent j'ai peur
qu'on lui fasse plus de mal que de bien
en prenant j'ai déjà du mal avec ce
qu'ils voient les leurs des drogues de
multiples qualités dans la crainte qui
était un peu d'art mauvaise foi un peu
enfin bon c'est en tout cas qui était
très négative et on voit bien que d'un
côté et quelqu'un le professeur de
karaté qui est volontaire qui envient et
puis vint cette urne war pilou doigt et
à l'oeil à côté vincent et des marocains
et puis de l'autre côté vous avez un
professeur responsable qui est dans la
crainte qui veut pas qu'il ya pas envie
qu'ils voient et radios sont sapés je
veux dire ils se séparent à l'issue
l'idée à mon sens emblématique et qu'il
fallait se rappeler que toute chose de
cette émission c'est que il faut que je
regarde société charge et pour qu'ils
chargent
il faut que les uns que le personnel
enfants handicapés soit un témoin inclus
à l'école ordinaire
on va on fait qu' on va venir les red
bull mais c'est celle avec bien sûr on
va venir à l'école parce que vous avez
raison c'est évidemment à monterey
importe il ya de la colère chez vous
parfois oui si vous voulez offrir
ça bouillonne mais vous entendez quand
même qu'on puisse vous dire vincent il
peut pas occuper tous les postes dans
une entreprise il est obligé il est qu
il est contraint un certain nombre de
postes
un certain nombre de tâches c'est vrai
il n'a pas pardonné - l'amplitude d'un
salarié lambda c'est vrai le handicap
il ya certaines limites il y a des
limites tout s'est dit on en a tous donc
l'idée une vie normale par exemple c'est
quoi c'est juste l'idée que étant donné
que chacun a ses limites il a besoin des
autres et que ayant besoin les autres
mondiaux une vie normale c'est juste une
vie au milieu des autres
ce qui revient un peu à la définition
que vous allez chercher chez freud c'est
qu'ils y travaillent et voilà après
quels sont exactement ces limites
c'est très compliqué à savoir génère
l'un des grands problèmes c'est
justement que chacun pense savoir
quelles sont les limites
alors qu'en vérité on n'en sait fichtre
rien il ya quelques dizaines d'années on
ne pensait pas qu'un jeune trisomique
pour lire écrire et compter
aujourd'hui manifestement pour peu que
l'éducation soit un petit peu bien fait
et savent lire écrire et compter
ils le travaillent par exemple a révélé
vincent à de nouvelles acquisitions
la de nouvelles choses ce que vous avez
vu se mettre au travail
rentrer dans le monde du travail ils ont
changé ils ont changé du tout au tout
j'ai passé trente ans donc à faire
sortir des jeunes d'un établissement
spécialisé donc institut
médico-professionnel au milieu ordinaire
de travail je peux vous affirmer vous
assurer que simplement pour des stages
jeunes est organisé à peu près mille
huit cents en 1915 jeudi stage ces
quatre semaines de travail dans le
milieu ordinaire entreprises mairies ou
autres lieux de travail
je peux vous affirmer vous assurer qu'à
chaque fois qu'on leur permettait
peut-être pour la première fois de leur
vie parce qu'ils avaient déjà tout un
parcours
un institutions spécialisées partir
demain ou leur permettait d'aller en
leur permettez je dis bien d'aller vers
le milieu ordinaire
il se passait quelque chose d'énorme et
un déclic le handicap demeure évidemment
si vous êtes trisomie que vous l'êtes
pour la ville si je suis bien mais on
les voyait chargé
je dirais presque du tout au tout il ya
quelque chose derrière ça qui me paraît
être du genre à b enfin je vais pouvoir
y aller dans ce fameux mans dans cet
autre monde dont on parlait tout à
l'heure et après tout comme papa comme
marrant comme ma soeur comme pierre et
paul
je vais peut être y arriver moi aussi
donc c'est extrêmement dynamisant cette
affaire là moi j'ai appelé sa dynamique
de progrès et on les voyait faire
jusqu'à un certain point parce que le
handicap est quand même là mais comme
vous disiez chers amis le handicap nous
en avons tous c'est moi qui parle j'ai
aussi les miens enfin on les voyait
progressé d'une manière tout à fait
étonnante et il n'aurait jamais
progressé de la sorte s'il était resté
un établissement spécialisé pour lés je
voudrais juste rajouter aller à une
chose garde on sait qu'il faut vraiment
qu'on pas moi j'appelle ça culture qu'on
passe d'une culture de
l'institutionnalisation des personnes
handicapées
je ne juge personne je suis pas là pour
porter dès ma faim on a beaucoup joué
avec saab
il faut qu'on passe maintenant une
véritable culture de l'inclusion des
personnes handicapées à l'école dans mon
arrivée on arrête de penser foyer on
pense qu'on arrête de penser tous les
coups ou presque variables qu'on arrête
de penser qu'un trisomique parce qu'il
est trisomique et bien ce serait bien
qu'ils rendent à une structure
spécialisée et qui n'est pas de sa vie
dont certains auront peut-être besoin de
la structure spécialisée parce que c'est
un degré dans la question que je me pose
est est-ce que tout le monde était prêt
à entrer dans le monde du travail
non alors il faut changer effectivement
un petit peu notre culture notre façon
de voir les choses en passeur d'une
notion de filière lui effectivement
rappelé au début puis on en reste dans
le milieu des institutions très bien à
une notion de parcours de dispositifs
etc
après il est quand même bien clair que
toute personne handicapée mentale ne se
retrouve pas forcément dans la meilleure
des nerfs ça ce n'est pas vrai nos
assemblées lire tout le monde n'est pas
apte c'est ça tout le monde ne trouvera
pas sa place son épanouissement
c'est pas qu'il soit question de bonheur
était pas un objectif en soi de la
meilleure dinars
un exemple simple une personne qui est
handicapé mental il ya un désaccord
ville et un corail sais quoi mais bien
sûr une personne qui à domicile qui
travaille dans le milieu ordinaire ou en
esat parce que j'y reviendrai les esat
sais pas quand mais maintenant fermement
il ya une ouverture et une mise à
disposition des thaïlandais dans les
entreprises les personnes peuvent aller
travailler directement à trouver en
ayant la sécurité de l'esap donc qu'il
ya quand même des choses qu'il faut dire
sur le 1000 institutionnel c'est pas le
milieu carcéral quoique très clairement
non mais c'est quoi c'est pas si on
arrive à le dire tout à fait ça comme
vous l'avez dit ceci et a donc je
reprends l'exemple d'une personne qui a
des classes 34 son domicile qui
travaillent en esat ou ou dans le milieu
ordinaire elle et le soir quand elle
rentre chez elle elle est souvent isolés
parce que la société elle est pas prête
à l'accueillir dans l'exemple vous êtes
arrivé à qui rentre bien dans ce club de
karaté mais vous dit vous dites est
moment donné que beaucoup d'autres clubs
ont refusé et donc finalement la vie la
vie sociale qu'on sait plus qu'à sept
personnes et pas forcément satisfaisant
donc il faut bien partir c'est ce qu'on
cherche c'est quand même
l'épanouissement de la personne le
travail est une façon de l'obtenir
et puis après il ya tout l'inclusion
sociale qui est ou qui est tout à fait
essentiel il faut entendre il faut payer
aux forceps
oui c'est une notion qui est très
importante dans la question de
l'inclusion sociale comme on dit de la
vie sociale de nos compatriotes avec des
handicaps c'est la notion
d'accompagnement
il faut penser l'accompagnement et vous
voyez quand on pense l'entreprise moi
j'ai un certain nombre de questions
j'aimerais poser notamment al groupe
accor si vincent n'était pas dans
l'équipe
que se passerait-il pour cette équipe
que diraient les collaborateurs de
l'équipe après le départ de vincent
qu'il n'était plus ils n'y étaient pas
aussi tout cela paraît très important à
signaler quand même on a besoin
d'entendre l'apport particulier et
singulier
je dirais irremplaçable de nos
compatriotes avec des handicaps dans
l'environnement de travail parce qu'il
adresse à l'environnement de travail un
certain nombre de critiques
deux remarques
extrêmement productive parce que des
salariés qui échoue au travail il y en a
un paquet dans la société française et
on ne veut pas dire qu'ils relèvent tous
d'une reconnaissance de qualité de
travailleur handicapé ça c'est le
premier point je vous donne un exemple
moi qu'on m'a raconté qu'il m'a
énormément frappé serbie on avait
proposé un emploi dans une entreprise de
grande distribution à une personne avec
une trisomie 21
ça semblait accessible parce que les
tâches étaient assez répétitive que
c'était assez facile de former la
personne et que globalement elle pouvait
être satisfaite elle réussissait à bien
faire son travail sauf que il y a eu un
petit problème les clients n'arrêtait
pas de passer dans le rayon et de
modifier tout le temps ce que la
personne avec son handicap
venez soigneusement d'ordonnancé vous
savez ce travail de fascines comme on
dit dans la grande distribution et ça
s'était accompagnée d'une très grande
souffrance dont la personne n'avait eu
du mal à parler avec son chef de rayon
parce que c'est ça le jeu dans les
grandes surfaces
on prend un paquet on le met elle est
donc ce travail soigneusement réalisé
qu'ils étaient en quelque sorte
déconstruit à chaque instant c'est ce
qui rendait la personne fragile et en
situation divisée s'il n'y a pas dans
l'environnement de travail quelqu'un
pour entendre ce problème là et pour
accompagner la personne avec son
handicap sur une meilleure résistance
aux traits au stress sur un
accompagnement peut-être périphérique
alors on peut le mettre en échec et donc
moi je dis que bien sûr il faut faire
appliquer la loi
mais vous avez raison pierre l'ag
l'enjeu maintenant c'est de faire que
notre société se pose les bonnes
questions et après d'elle-même au
contact de nos compatriotes avec des
handicaps extrêmement convaincu de cette
dimension grecque on regarde du côté de
l'école
on lit beaucoup en tout cas la
documentation qui m'est parvenue d'issac
les chiffres de scolarisation sont en
hausse que ça s'améliore du côté de la
scolarisation des enfants handicapés en
général et handicapés mentaux en
particulier mais quand on pense à ce
sujet du handicap à l'école on repense
pardonnez moi c'est un tropisme
politique sans doute on repense à cet
échange très vif entre nicolas sarkozy
et ségolène royal souvenez-vous 2007 le
débat présidentiel scandale qu'un enfant
ayant un handicap ne puisse pas être
scolarisés dans une école entre
guillemets normal si je suis élu
président de la république je ferais une
place à chacun des enfants donne dans
nos écoles que je donnerai les moyens
aux écoles pour les accueillir et que la
preuve de ma bonne foi et la certitude
de la réalisation de cette promesse ça
sera le droit opposable et la capacité
d'aller devant un tribunal pour faire
valoir ses droits jouer avec le handicap
comme vous venez de le faire est
proprement scandaleux c'est moi qui ai
créé le plan en 10 cols qui a demandé à
toutes les écoles d'accueillir tous les
enfants handicapés
c'est votre gouvernement qui a supprimé
non seulement le plan dix cols qui a
supprimé les aides éducateurs et qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui moins d'un enfant
sur deux qui étaient accueillis il y a
cinq ans dans l'école de la république
ne le sont plus aujourd'hui non monsieur
sarkozy tout n'est pas possible dans la
vie politique tout n'est pas possible ce
discours cet écart entre le discours et
des seins et les actes surtout lorsqu'il
s'agit d'enfants handicapés n'est pas
acceptable
évidemment on va pas refaire le débat
c'est pas le sujet mais quand vous êtes
devant votre poste peut-être ce soir là
en 2007 vous vous dites en entendant ça
enfin on parle de nous à la télé au
niveau national où vous dites mais c'est
pas possible on parle encore de ça du
handicap de cette manière
le problème c'est que je ne sais pas
exactement ce qui est vrai ou faux dans
ce qui je vous demande pas d'arbitré
entre les deux là c'est pas le sujet
vraiment mais ce que je sais c'est
qu'effectivement ségolène royal a fait
des choses pour la bonne raison que
effectivement j'avais une bonne amie qui
est qui avait à sa tête
à l'époque leur set et quand je voudrais
pas dire nabil titre fin des années 90
où peut-être début des années 2000 à
l'époque ségolène royal était ministre
des écoles et claudine et claude allègre
est chapeautée un ministère plus globale
est effectivement cet ami avait intenté
un procès à l'éducation nationale parce
que
son fils était en intégration
individuels lesquels avec les moyens
n'étaient pas amis comme ils auraient dû
l'être et ségolène royal a effectivement
admis avoir que l'état français a le
temps et a essayé de faire effectivement
des choses elle a effectivement mis en
place un certain nombre de choses à
l'époque là dessus ça c'est vrai et sur
les cols bleus réellement ça avance ou
pas oui oui oui c'est pour vincent ça
s'est passé comment alors le problème de
vincent c'est que jusqu'à il est plus ou
moins sur le front de vagues alors c'est
pas tout à fait vrai parce qu'avant la
réforme ou juste après on est la
génération si vous voulez qui a poussé
qui a poussé à l'intégration massivement
avant nous il y avait des gens qui
intégrait et qui faisait de
l'intégration avec leurs enfants mais
c'étaient des cas très particulier et
très isolés on est la première
génération qui a ont peut-être assumer
ses enfants et a dit on veut qu'on a eu
on a eu envie qu'on les voit enfin non
pas qu'on les voie pour qu'on les montre
juste qu'on les voit parce que voilà
maxime logos depuis qu'ils sont sympas
et qu'il n'y a pas de raison et a plein
de raisons de faire différemment et dans
cette mesure là si vous voulez vincent a
toujours et ça a toujours été compliqué
parce que il est rentré dans une école
parisienne
à l'époque il y avait une classe
intégrée dans une école à paris dans le
public après quand il est sorti de ceux
de cette école il a fallu qui est d'une
classe en collège ça n'existait pas il a
fallu faire ouvrir la khl a toujours une
bagarre donc c'est toujours toujours
tout a été une bague en touche avec
quelquefois des bons moments
j'entends à faut pas exagérer non plus
c'est à dire qu'on est remarquable avec
des fois on a eu un super prof avec une
vraie discussion il y avait une
collaboration il y avait pouvait
on pouvait penser les choses ensemble
alors c'est pas simple on n'est pas
forcément d'accord il ya l'immense
problème qui consiste à entre comment
vous dire ça une sorte de décalage
fondamentale entre le temps
institutionnels il tombe nos enfants ou
temps les familles c'est à dire que
l'école il ya un petit problème bon on
va voir ça pour l'année prochaine
non oui c'est même temps c'est votre
moment voilà mon fiston il va perdre et
à la fois les temps sont plus longs
parce que pour apprendre à lire avec
quand on est porteur d'une trisomie bas
il est pas forcément dit que ça se passe
en cp à propos du récent mais voilà il
ya une vraie différence entre l'étang
institutionnel elle tend même temps et
le temps de la vie aujourd'hui quelle
est la proportion pourcentage d'enfants
handicapés mentaux qui sont scolarisés
la proportion n'a pas de signes de sens
a indiqué la scolariser connaît on sait
qu'il ya treize mille enfants seuls sur
la source de ces naissances qui n'ont
pas de solution éducative du treize
mille enfants sans solutions sont donc
pas du tout mais après deux ans chante
mais des questions scolarisés difficile
y en a qui peuvent être scolarisés une
heure par semaine
il y en a qui peuvent être scolarisés le
premier trimestre puis reprise 260 ceux
qui aiment bien
alors certes oppresseurs de la connaît
il ya des personnes qui sont certes des
enfants qui sont certainement domicile
avec leur part et qu'ils n'ont pas
manifesté leurs auditeurs ses parents
par exemple de ne garder plus vos
enfants à la maison
si vous pensez que c'est bien pour eux
d'aller à l'école vous y avez droit la
loi enfin oui bon d'accord mais on voit
bien combien c'est difficile mais macha
la loi bien entendu mais il n'y a pas il
n'y a pas que la loi qui compte mais
aujourd'hui la loi dispose que tous les
enfants de la république doivent être
scolarisés à l'école de la république
donc si la réponse par je ne sais quel
hasard ou mauvaise volonté et non pas
pas le vôtre l'action est possible et
elle est fondée sur un texte qui est la
loi du 11 février 2005
par ailleurs ce que le législateur a
voulu
c'est qu'il a voulu faire en sorte que
ce ne soit pas l'école qui disent non ou
qui disent pas comme ça la confrontation
entre l'enfant et l'école est terrible
quand on demande à l'école d'expliquer
aux parents ou à l'enfant que pour lui
c'est pas possible ça n'est pas dans ce
lieu là que les choses doivent se passer
ça doit se passer dans des lieux dédiés
qui sont des centres approche précoce du
handicap les quais les cams par exemple
c'est dont l'accompagnement de la
famille à mieux appréhender à mieux
comprendre le handicap de son enfant
mais ça n'est pas dans la confrontation
violente du milieu scolaire avec
l'enfant et la famille qu'il faut que
ces choses là prennent place et la loi
la loi le permet désormais alors vous
avez raison de dire des hommes
elle donne des armes et hispania une
référence absolue républicaine est
absolument d'accord avec ces notions là
à dire qu'il ya des pays où je pense ici
tout le monde le sait pays du nord et
l'italie entre autres ou en italie à ma
connaissance tous les enfants handicapés
peut-être à quelques exceptions près
vente à l'école de tous alors je dis pas
que tout est parfait que tout se passe
dans le meilleur des mondes mais les
enfants handicapés vont à l'école avec
des structures en forme et et renforts
je mens avec le personnel nécessaire et
c'est moins que mardi quand le maudit
parce que je sais que souvent les
personnellement que dans les écoles ou
n'ont pas la formation évolue et ses
excès mais dans les structures
spécialisées y mpm promis et mieux je
dis ce que je pense
il y en a du personnel spécialisé il ya
des instituteurs spécialisés il ya des
éducateurs il ya des assistantes
sociales
j'ai vécu moi dans ce type
d'établissement qu'est ce qu'on attend
pour faire glisser un petit peu tout ce
monde là vers l'école ordinaire il
aligner pas le coin droit ou des réacs
alors je voudrais terminer 6e
permutations pourquoi pourquoi faut-il
toujours moyen un truc que je ne
supporte pas c'est que tu es handicapé
donc tu iras dans une structure
spécialisée ça j'ai bien compris votre
point caire tout à fait et ce que je
voulais ajouter aussi ici je pense tout
le monde le sait aussi c'est que l'école
avance effectivement il ya des progrès
qui se font c'est pas moi qui viendrait
dire le contraire
il ya des choses qu'on voyait pas il ya
encore un certain nombre d'années qu'on
voit maintenant mais il ya beaucoup
d'eau mais derrière tout ça je parle
toujours du handicap mental
bon il ya certain nombre de jeunes
handicapés mentaux qui sont intégrés
dans des collèges mais après que
devient-il et vous le savez sûrement
aussi bien que moi on sait plus très
bien
et j'entends parler bien il vous ayez
ils vont pas au lycée la saison ils
sortent d'une mairie marc desplats ce
programme a en lycées professionnels où
on n'a pas le savoir-faire ou le vouloir
faire aussi et je sais pertinemment que
ce nombre d'entre eux sont orientés vers
l'âge de 14 ou 16 ans vers les externats
les instituts médico professionnel donc
ils ont été dans un cadre on les range
dans l'annuaire de but et parce qu'elle
sait pas quoi en faire si vous voulez on
les envoie à nouveau dans le monde du
handicap sans leur demander leur avis ni
celui des parents les tournages et
rosamond l'aspect le para préjugés parce
qu'on sait pas faire maintenant on sait
pas ce qu'on sait pas faire et on n'a
pas les moyens de faire ou parce qu'on
ne veut pas faire c'est plus facile avec
un handicap moteur
pardon de le dire aussi probablement
enfin il y à de grandes objectivement
comme un gros problème d'accessibilité y
compris elle aussi pour les
naturellement et puis vous savez que des
bagarres quand le handicap moteur est
très lourd et sa compagne de sur un
handicap alors là les objections sont
massifs voyez prenez le cas d'un enfant
trachéotomisés sa place à l'école est
très compliqué comment faire entrer le
soin dans l'école pour ça c'est quelque
chose qui reste encore très très très
réticents mais je pense que sur la
question du handicap mental
des progrès ont été faits notamment au
niveau du premier degré il faut que si
vous voulez il faut éviter les ruptures
et l'exemple que vous donnez de ce
retour dans le milieu du handicap ce
qu'on me dit c'est la négation plus que
c'est la négation de cet effort
collectif des parents et de la personne
qui un jour a bien voulu faire face pu
faire face au milieu ordinaire
alors les réussites dans le meilleur dit
pardon réussi dans le meilleur des
nécessite toujours à faire en tout cas
moi c'est mon ex place est-ce que j'ai
une balle
une bagarre entre jean parent une
bagarre pour les profanes mais rien n
est acquis il faut toujours se bagarrer
et je trouve ça un peu un peu gros pour
l'intro de pour les familles pour les
parents déjà qu'ils ont enfin d'accepter
un enfant trisomique ce n'est pas
toujours facile aussi
il faut pas tomber dans le tout est beau
tout est millions mais enfin que c'est
par là et toujours à se bagarrer plus
que les autres pour que leur fils ou
leur fille arrive à quelque chose je
trouve ça calme qui a joué un rôle à
monsieur la gym et je voudrais vous où
l'on revoit parce que puisqu'on parlait
de bagarres et de difficultés un moment
qui est très émouvant dans le film c'est
le moment où vous craquez edouard cruel
les nuages s'accumulent le lycée ne veut
pas prendre 20 cents en gaap et enfin le
cfa plus exactement le centre de
formation des apprentis ne votera non il
à la digue lâche il ya plein de
problèmes à résoudre
voilà c'est parce qu'il faut tenir ou
pas le dire maman va l'appeler monsieur
lucas parce qu'il faut qu'on comprend à
tout prix parce que si on n'a pas tant
contre 1 ça marche
le propos ce qu il est là pour vous
aussi
thébaux ce solide c'est la fatigue oui
on imagine bien que c'est la fatigue
puis à cette histoire de voiture qu'à
lâcher enfin on voit bien qu'il ya de la
goutte d'eau là dedans on voit bien que
c'est rude et que peut-être d'autre part
en lâchant route parce qu'on est trop
différente la dépression se rencontrent
pas souvent chez en particulier chez
chez les mères mais comment vous dire
moi ce que ça m'a appris et ce qu'ils
font enfin ce que j'aimerais que les
autres apprennent aussi c'est que la
gueule la question la plus intéressante
pas se poser c'est comment est ce qu'il
faut faire pour que ça marche alors que
souvent on a devant nous des gens qui
pensent ouais mais les choses sont comme
ça il peut pas et là est la vraie façon
de prendre les choses c'est bon t'es
lequel il peut pas comment est ce qu'on
va faire pour qu'ils puissent et c'est
toujours une écoute on se dit tiens on
regarde comment est ce qu'il fait
pourquoi
qu'est ce qu'on peut améliorer qu'est-ce
qu'on peut changer qu'est ce qu'on peut
apporter
qu'est ce qui est vraiment nécessaire
dans ce qui est requis qu'est ce qu'il
l'est pas vraiment qu'est ce que c'est
si vous voulez c'est un questionnement
pratique c'est une écoute c'est une une
attention au cas par cas
c'est toute une série de choses comme ça
qu'aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de mal à
faire le principe de compensation
c'est une façon de respecter le principe
d'égalité car je crois compensation il
est dans la loi devrait 2005
c'est me donner les moyens pour essayer
d'accéder un égalisateur alors que je
suis en difficulté
voila voila je le dis honte elle c'était
la sphère simplement telle situation je
suis en difficulté donc comment est ce
qu'on va pouvoir aménager la situation
pour que je le sois moi
grosso modo le principe de compensation
et le principe de compensation il est
pensé comme un peu comment dire une un
pilier du principe d'égalité
mais en face de nous on essaie quand
même assez souvent aussi qu'on trouve
des gens qui pensent légalité de façon
opposée c'est à dire l'égalité c'est ça
le l'examen par exemple c'est çà çà çà
çà rsa les horaires c'est çà çà çà çà çà
et vous si une personne est intégrée
elle fait juste
exactement comme les autres parce que si
elle fait pas exactement comme les
autres après le principe d'égalité est
rompu par exemple alors que celle
inverse enfin sedan et son ca puisque
vincent rate son ca fait bon ménage
ah oui c'est une question pour pourrait
dire après tout on met des moyens
puisqu'il veut vivre avec si vous voulez
de par exemple alors après je sais pas
exactement ce qui s'est passé parce que
avec le lycée hôtelier le problème c'est
qu'ils ne nous parlait pas parce que
vous leur avez un point
on voit dans moi non mais l'académie oui
il ya des bills a fait votre demande oui
oui
non moi je t'ai d'accord pour eux il ay
éventuellement ailleurs jeu si vous
voulez l'eau l'un des grands problèmes
par exemple de ce que disait nicolas
sarkozy en disant le principe de comment
dire que droit opposable c'est qu'on ne
peut pas passer notre temps en procès et
qu'on a la trouille pour nos gosses
aussi on il s'agit aussi que nos gosses
soit bien reçu
donc moi si je sens que mon gosse est
mal reçu quelque part je vais pas non
plus forcément poussé à tout prix pour
qu'il y ait quand même donc a priori si
le lycée hôtelier ne voulait pas de
vincent moi j'étais aussi mal
j'étais un peu partagé parce que d'un
côté j'ai envie de dire bon écoutez vous
êtes obligé de le prendre donc prenez le
et d'un autre côté j'ai envie de dire
aussi moi j'ai aussi envie que mon gosse
soit heureux puissent travailler dans de
bonnes conditions et si celle ci chez
vous c'est pas possible je préfère qu'il
aille ailleurs c'est la contradiction
permanente dans lequel les enfants les
parents d'enfants handicapés sont les
familles se retrouvent confrontés en
permanence à ses réticences
les familles sont toujours confrontés à
des obstacles mais si elles font le
deuil et assure une intégration de leurs
enfants à un moment alors au fond je
pense jamais le deuil mais ils sont
obligés
ça va faire le deuil elles se retrouvent
dans des situations où elle ne peut pas
peuvent pas faire autrement
moi je voudrais quand même revenir un
peu sur l'école pour tous c'est un droit
qui est dans la loi et qui effectivement
n'a pas de raisons je vous rejoins sur
ce point là il n'y a pas de raison que
tous les enfants ne soient pas l'école
ordinaire
après il faut pas les opposer aux
institutions osier mais c'est deux
choses qui sont différentes pour que
l'accès à l'école ordinaire soit réelle
et se passe dans de bonnes conditions
ben c'est simple il faut que les moyens
qui sont mis dans nos institutions
quand il répète comme ça dans nos mails
soient à l'école parce que ce qu'on rêve
au niveau de l'unapei
hier de simple c'est que les iem il soit
dans l'enceinte de l'école
et parce que si vous l'exemple du cff
dont je connais pas le cas particulier
mais c'est vrai que si le professeur il
a pas eu de formation qui n'a jamais
rencontré des enfants handicapés
il sait pas bien faire il c'est parce
qu'il a peur parce qu'il est pas à son
aise voilà ça peut il peut pas s'en
sortir pas content si on lui met en
place un accompagnement comme on fait
par exemple dans les sessad sessad
service d'éducation spécialisée et de
soins à domicile donc vous avez des
structures médico sociales qui va dans
l'école qui accompagnent l'enfant à
l'école dans des classes spécialisées ou
non puis qu'il va aussi adam famille
soupçonné al shamikha accessoires tout
ce que vous dites qu'il va pas très
souvent cet accompagnement cela veut
dire qu'il permet l'adhésion ça ne
marche pas mais à la carte en fonction
de ce qui est possible
j'entends tellement bien sûr et surtout
rompre avec cette vision vertical est
fermée exclusif des solutions
l'idée c'est le parcours c'est la
transversalité l'école doit être partout
où sont les enfants est évidemment où
sont les enfants avec des handicaps mais
vous savez c'est un blog c'est un propos
qui est politique
notre société souffre énormément de ces
cloisonnement et avec la question du
handicap et de ses transversalité je
crois que c'est une véritable bouffée
d'espoir pour sortir notre société ces
contraintes
merci à tous les quatre à avoir débattu
merci pour votre film je cite à nouveau
qu'elle breton qui a co réalisé ce
documentaire absolument magnifique
je vous laisse réagir et continue de
réagir évidemment sur le mail de
l'émission qui s'affiche en bas de votre
écran
la semaine seule la semaine prochaine
vous avez rendez vous et que claire
barsacq pour un débat sur la place des
femmes dans les religions
là aussi c'est un sacré débat à très
vite sur public sénat
hu